schon wieder nur eine woche nach den
ausschreitungen in einem berliner
freiheit ist es wieder zu brutalen
gewalt gekommen und schon wieder in
einem berliner schwimmbad diesmal in
berlin neukölln
dort eskalierte ein streit und alles
fing wieder mit wasserpistolen an was
ist nur los in unseren freibädern
bilder die schockieren massenschlägerei
in einem berliner schwimmbad nur eine
woche nach diesem brutalen bildern jetzt
der nächste fall schon wieder gewalt im
freibad und wieder in berlin im
columbiadamm in neukölln eskalierte ein
streit zwischen besuchern der auslöser
schon wieder wasserpistolen kann ich
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen folglich
wie es dann so immer eskalieren kann
damit gleich irgendwie hunderten leuten
die sich danach gegenseitig an die
gurgel gehen und vor einer woche sorgten
diese szenen für schlagzeilen eine
massenschlägerei im berliner sommerbad
in steglitz junge männer prügeln wild
aufeinander ein familien ergreifen die
flucht als sicherheitskräfte schlichten
wollen eskaliert die situation am ende
sind an der schlägerei rund 100 leute
beteiligt bilder die fassungslos machen
auf den tag genau eine woche später
spielen sich ähnliche szenen im
columbiadamm in neukölln ab das in der
vergangenheit schon oft für negative
schlagzeilen sorgte prallen hier zu
viele menschen aufeinander ist hier
einfach zu viel das wird auch jetzt
schon gut gefüllt dann auch sein dass
man einfach immer zu viel auf einem
haufen sind die dann
zu viel testosteron versprühen wie kommt
dazu dass hundert leute auf einem
offenen losgehen dann müsste sich der
noch mit einer der noch mit ein und
dennoch mit einer drei mal ist das aus
ihrer sicht jetzt
besorgniserregend dass solche vorfälle
in freibädern häufiger auftreten mit
solcher im solchen ausmaßen dann
natürlich ist das besorgniserregend das
klingt ja wie kinder daten dass man sich
dann ernsthaft schlagen muss oder mit
messern zu stechen musste es ist sehr
überhitzt vielleicht ist es auch dem
wetter geschuldet aber das muss ja nicht
sein
bei der jüngsten eskalation in berlin
neukölln wurde die polizei von 250
badegästen bedrängt eine frau war mit
wasserpistolen bespritzt worden
daraufhin eskalierte der streit ein mann
schlug der frau mit der spielzeugwaffe
ins gesicht und brach ihr die nase doch
ist die gewalt in freibädern nur ein
berliner phänomen die jugend her sind
mehr machen mehr ärger als anderer
bezahlt ich glaube das ist ein phänomen
hier von neukölln dass die die
jugendlichen sind hier nicht lässt sich
ja ich denke dass die jugendlichen in
berlin und speziell in diesem bezirk
auch dazu neigen überhitzt zu reagieren
aggressiv zu sein ja die gewalt in
berliner freibädern deutschlands
oberster bademeister ist schockiert über
diese ausmaße jetzt erschüttert mich
damit diese löhne wieder sehen die haben
wir vor die krone haben hier schon mal
ja und zwar wurden in düsseldorf und
kehl am rhein in anderen orten auch viel
gebaut daten verzeichnet ich könnte hier
nicht mehr von hormonen sprechen die das
land ein bisschen spielen
es ist eine entwicklung die mir ein
bisschen zu denken wagt er sich damals
schon nicht angefangen als ich gesagt
habe ich habe sorge dass demnächst nach
oben security in ein freibad gehen
können die person die ich erzähle im
moment haben keinen respekt mehr
vorderleuten und wenn ich dann auch noch
zum aussprechen dass ich hier vorwiegend
leute mit migrationshintergrund sehe
also auch verschiedene kulturelle leben
da muss ich sagen das kann so nicht
weitergeht seit den vorfällen am
wochenende stellt sich eine frage werden
unsere freibäder zum logo
fest steht diese bilder sollte es in
zukunft nicht mehr geben
wirklich unfassbare bilder und dieses
thema müssen wir vertiefen mit benjamin
landreau er ist pressesprecher bei der
gewerkschaft der polizei in berlin herr
landreau schönen guten tag schön dass
sie bei uns sind ganz im ernst ich habe
zwei kleine kinder zwei und drei jahre
alt wenn es heißt raus ist dann wollen
wir natürlich gern ins freibad gehen
aber ich habe angst ich will da nicht
mehr hin zu recht montag erstmal also
ich kann ihre ängste natürlich
nachvollziehen wenn wir diese bilder
sehen und da hat ihr kollege ja gerade
auch den den beitrag ganz gut beendet
bilder die auch angst machen und ich
glaube dass das geht vielen menschen so
auf der anderen seite sollten wir das
auch mal ein bisschen sachlicher
einordnen also es ist eben nicht nur so
lasse das in freibädern in berlin
passiert und wir können gerne mal ein
paar pressemitteilung von vor 10 15
jahren durchgehend da ist das genauso
passiert das leider immer so wenn viele
menschen an einem ort sind und
aufeinander sind dann ist es vielleicht
auch heute ganz gut also mal ein
bisschen regnet auch wenn ihr kollege
auf dem dach ein bisschen nach dem popo
hat aber vielleicht ganz gut dass mal
ein bisschen runter gekühlt wird und wir
haben natürlich bei dem band jetzt am
wochenende des columbia hat ja da sind
viele junge männer die vielleicht ein
bisschen testosteron geladen dort rein
gehen aber es ist auch kein phänomen das
nur auf menschen mit
migrationshintergrund zu treten deswegen
sollten wir sachlich einordnen harzheim
hat glaube ich gerade ganz gut gesagt
wir müssen vielleicht mehr
sicherheitspersonal auch in die bäder
bringen um da solche situationen nicht
komplett verhindern zu können das wird
nie gelingen aber vielleicht das risiko
zu minimieren dass da leute aufeinander
losgehen trotzdem hat man den eindruck
dass ich das häuft in letzter zeit und
dass das auch in berlin sehr sehr oft
passiert für mich war das freibad auch
wenn sie sagen das hat es schon immer
gegeben wo viele menschen aufeinander
treffen für mich war das irgendwie
bisher kein ort den ich als bedrohung
wahrgenommen habe hat sich da
irgendetwas verändert glauben sie dass
ich in unserem klima in unserem
gesellschaftlichen klima irgendetwas
verändert hat und was können wir tun so
mehr sicherheitspersonal mehr kontrollen
was sind die möglichkeiten dass man
keine angst haben muss und das ist
wirklich eine absolute ausnahme ist das
nicht mal in meinem hinterkopf haben
mehr angst ist immer subjektiv
wahrgenommen und man muss auch ehrlich
sagen sie sitzen hier in berlin gerade
im beitrag gehört das übrigens auch in
nrw passiert und geführt das waren jetzt
die letzten zwei wochenenden jeweils
einen sohn vorfall aber es gibt auch
viele freibäder wo es gesittet zuging
deswegen darf man sich jetzt auch nicht
von der macht der bilder blenden lassen
die sicherlich eine andere ist als vor
15 jahren aber ich will das auch gar
nicht klein reden das ist ein phänomen
und das auch eine aufgabe für politik in
erster linie sind aus unserer sicht auch
die bezog in der fans die beträge ganz
einfach und die betreiber der einzelnen
freiwilliger und die polizei steht da
gerne mit expertise dabei wo wir werden
nicht immer mit funk waren dort stehen
können ja das heißt man kann es
sicherlich über taschenkontrollen die
aber ohnehin freiwillig vom stadt sind
kann man es vielleicht ein bisschen
reglementieren und sicherlich auch wenn
man sich die bilder angucken da sind
sehr viele menschen auf engem raum ja
kontingente maximal 500 aber es gibt
keine allgemeine lösung weil jedes bad
es auch anders ja und wir wollen glaube
ich auch die freibäder sie wollen dahin
wir haben jetzt in dem beitrag viele
menschen gesehen die dahin wollen
vielleicht auch mit ihren kindern das
darf keine no go area werden ist aber
auch nicht aber trotzdem sollte man die
bilder sich glaube ich genau vor augen
führen ob es jetzt wirklich zugenommen
hat also ich kenne keine zahlen die das
bestätigen so ehrlich muss man auch
sagen ihnen auch die beamtinnen und
beamten im einsatz man hat das gefühl
die sind derzeit mehr damit beschäftigt
kleben der hände von ministerien und von
autobahnen zu lösen als vielleicht dann
doch jetzt gerade dieser phase mal mit
einem einsatzwagen dort stehen zu können
haben sie das gefühl dass das auch für
frust bei den beamten oder sagen sie
auch das einfach alltag bei der polizei
kennen also müssen schon auch sagen das
war jetzt vielleicht ein speziell auf
einem columbia war dann wollen wir aber
das ist alltag auf berlins straßen und
wiesen die hauptstadt passiert alles ja
also hier kleben sich nicht nur klima
aktivisten oder straftäter terroristen
man sie hätte nennen möchte kleben sie
sich dort fest sondern wir haben eben
auch ganz ganz viele kolleginnen und
kollegen gerade zum g7-gipfel geschickt
ja die also hier fehlen und die aufgaben
in der hauptstadt werden nicht weniger
tagtäglich passiert was vielleicht in
einer anderen stadt der aufreger in zehn
jahren wäre also so ehrlich muss man
schon sein natürlich kann man dann
gerade im sommer auch die wohl danach
stellen dass wieder ein anruf kommt vor
dem freibad dass man raus fahren muss
und ja die kolleginnen und kollegen
boden gern kriminalität verhindern und
nicht wegen sowas da immer raus fahren
müssen aber klar es ist dann eben doch
irgendwann polizeiliche aufgabe man muss
halt irgendwann davon wegkommen dass
polizei und feuerwehren der in der stadt
hier irgendwie motiv für alles sind hier
müssen andere auch mal in ihrer
verantwortung kommen und wie gesagt wir
beraten da gern ja aber es kann auch
nicht sein dass die bäder sich jetzt
zurückziehen und sagen eure polizei
kommt dann irgendwie
hoffen wir mal alle zusammen dass das
nicht mehr allzu oft passiert